[Musique]
vient d'avoir les chiffres de
contamination des dernières 24 heures
dans notre pays
j'avais parlé des risques d'avoir quinze
ou vingt mille cas par jour à la fin du
mois de juillet nous étions lui hier à
18000 contamination sur 24 heures
seulement
cela veut dire que nous avons une
augmentation de la circulation du virus
de leurs de 150% sur une semaine nous
n'avons jamais connu cela avec locaux
vides
diack le barrio anglais né avec le sud
africain a nié que le brésilien oui nous
avons une arme la vaccination
oui nous avons des vaccins oui nous
mobilisons les centres les médecins des
pharmaciens les infirmiers partout sur
tout le territoire national est tout le
temps et nous invitons les français à se
connecter massivement aux plateformes
aller voir leur centre prendre
rendez-vous consulter leur médecin
le temps n'est plus aux doutes le temps
n'est plus à l'hésitation le temps est à
l'immunité collective
c'est de la responsabilité collective et
c'est le seul moyen que nous avons et
nous l'utiliserons à bon escient de nous
débarrasser ducobu une fois pour toutes